Auf der diesjährigen E3 in Los Angeles wurden
wieder eine Menge spannende Spiele vorgestellt.
Doch das Thema, auf das fast jeder immer wieder
zu sprechen kam war Virtual Reality. Oculus
stellte nun endlich die finale Version ihres
Headsets vor und Microsoft demonstrierte eindrucksvoll
wie Mincecraft mit der Hololens-Brille aussehen
könnte. Was ist heute schon mit virtueller
Realität möglich? Und was bleibt noch Science
Fiction? Die Antwort gibt es jetzt bei What’s on.
Herzlich Willkommen zu einer weiteren Folge
What’s on. Die Möglichkeit in andere Welten
einzutauchen um Abenteuer zu erleben und dabei
die echte Welt zu vergessen wurde uns schon
einmal versprochen. Doch Anfang der Neunziger
war die Consumer-Technik noch nicht bereit.
Schlechte Screens und eine zu starke Verzögerung
verursachten Kopfschmerzen.
Doch seit die Oculus Rift auf Kickstarter
mit 2,5 Millionen US-Dollar unterstützt wurde
ist die ganze Technikbranche im Virtual Reality-Fieber.
HTC, Sony, Microsoft oder Samsung.
Fast jede größere Technikfirma hat in den
letzten zwei Jahren ihren Versuch vorgestellt
die virtuelle Welt zu erobern.
Aber wovon reden wir hier eigentlich? Zuerst
sollte man zwischen zwei unterschiedlichen
Formen von VR unterscheiden. Virtual Reality
und Augmented Reality.
Bei letzterem „Augmented Reality“ sieht
man die echte Welt durch eine Glasscheibe.
Wenn das Gerät ausgeschaltet ist kann man
normal sehen, aber eingeschaltet fügt das Gerät
digitale Objekte zu deiner normalen
Sicht hinzu.
Von Navigationspfeilen über Fotos bis hin
zu richtigen Bildschirmen kann das alles sein.
Bekannte Beispiele hierfür sind das Google
Glass und Microsofts neues Hololens. Der große
Hype im Google Glass ist inzwischen vollkommen
abgeklungen. Und man wird wider Erwarten nicht
ständig von Brillenträgern gefilmt.
Wahrscheinlich hat Google testen wollen wie
die Technik bei den Menschen ankommt und ob
sie dafür schon bereit sind und ich denke,
dass sich eins der vielen Projekte bei Google X
immer noch mit einer Virtual Reality Brille
beschäftigt und wir in den nächsten Jahren
Googles zweiten Versuch sehen werden.
Doch dafür ist jetzt Microsofts Hololens
der große Hype. Die Demo hat viel versprochen.
Ein Computer, der immer bei mir ist, wenn
ich ihn brauche. Fenster, die mir folgen und
die ich überall hinpinnen kann, sodass meine
Umwelt quasi zu meinem Desktop wird. Wie in
Iron Man.
Doch auch Hololens hat noch Probleme. Primär
ein sehr kleines Sichtfeld, in dem die Grafiken
angezeigt werden können. Von der 360° Reality
kann hier kaum die Rede sein.
Trotzdem glaube ich, dass Augmented Reality
eine sehr große Zukunft hat. Mit ihr kann
ich besser kommunizieren, wichtige Sachen
im Blick behalten und verliere trotzdem die
richtige Welt nicht aus den Augen. Augmented
Reality fügt unserer echten Welt ein paar
Features hinzu, ohne sie komplett zu ersetzen.
Im Gegensatz dazu schaut man bei Virtual Reality
auf einen Bildschirm. Alles, was man sieht
wird vom Computer vorher berechnet. Das ist
zum einem natürlich rechenaufwendiger, bietet
aber viel mehr Potential für eine komplette
Immersion.
Entstanden ist Virtual Reality beim Militär,
wo es für Simulationen verwendet wird, die
man nicht in der echten Welt durchführen
sollte. Zum Beispiel das trainieren von Bruchlandungen
in einem Kampfjet.
Auch Soldaten trainieren mit VR-Headsets immer
häufiger knifflige Gefahrensituationen. Und
spätestens da werden natürlich die Gamer
hellhörig. Doch bis wir, wie in "Gamer", komplett
in eine Welt eintauchen können wird es wohl
noch einige Jahre dauern.
Viele der Simulationen, die es im Moment zu
testen gibt, sind eben genau das. Simulationen.
Es fehlen noch die richtigen Spiele, die extra
für das Spielen mit VR-Headsets designt wurden.
Die interessantesten Spiele im Moment sind
Star Citizen und E-VR (Eve VR, eine Adaption
von Eve Online)
Solche Flugsimulationen wie hier sind prädestiniert für VR-Gaming. Weil die virtuelle Realität, sitzend in einem Cockpit,
relativ nah an die Wirklichkeit herankommt. Nämlich sitzend auf der Couch.
Die größten Spieler auf dem Virtual Reality
Markt sind im Moment Oculus Rift, Sonys Morpheus
und das erst kürzlich vorgestellte Vive von
HTC und Steam-Hersteller Valve.
Zumindest die ersten beiden konnte ich bereits
antesten und ich muss sagen: Es ist definitiv
ein komplett neues Gefühl. Sobald man den
Kopf bewegt fühlt man sich viel tiefer in
der Spielwelt als es jemals mit einem Monitor
möglich wäre.
Aber es gibt auch Probleme. Dadurch dass die
Screens so nah vor dem Auge sitzen kann man
zum Beispiel relativ leicht einzelne Pixel
erkennen.
Aber wir sind definitiv auf dem
richtigen Weg und ich glaube gerne, das die
dritte oder vierte Version der Headsets einen
denken lassen kann, dass man wirklich IN der
Welt ist.
Also wer weiß schon ob es bald total normal
sein wird im Park Minecraft zu spielen?
Allerdings glaube ich, dass Gaming nur ein
kleiner Bereich dessen sein wird, was revolutioniert
wird. Die ganze Art und Weise wie wir kommunizieren
könnte sich verändern.
Hier in der ‚New York University‘ werden
zum Beispiel die Grenzen von virtueller Realität
ausgetestet. Dabei können zum Beispiel Menschen
mithilfe von 3-Dimensionalen Zeichnungen viel
besser verdeutlichen, worum es ihnen geht.
So wie zur Zeit der ersten Mobiltelefone noch
keiner ahnen konnte zu was Smartphones heute
in der Lage sind, so kann auch heute noch keiner erahnen, was VR mit unserem Leben in der Zukunft anstellen wird.
Viele Experten sind der Meinung, dass Virtual
Reality ein eigenes Medium ist, so wie das
Fernsehen oder das Internet. Und wenn man
sich vorstellt welchen Einfluss diese Dinge
auf unser alltägliches Leben hatten, dann
fällt es schwer Virtual Reality nicht spannend
zu finden.
Ein großes Dankeschön geht an den YouTube
Kanal PhysicallyShaken für die geilen Animationen
in diesem Video und an Ken Perlin von der
New York University für das Bereitstellen
vieler Videos und einen tollen Vortrag.